and when I started to became violent
against people I grew as well because
before I was a person everybody laughed
about when I had some notes or anything
yeah and now now the people started to
fear me
so
um yeah I was maybe not happy but I felt
uh the first time after many years being
part of something when you were part of
the Neo-Nazi movement
um and you and you stand up in the
morning when you drink your first tea
and you hate you hate all day
and uh and you listen to music and you
hang around with comrades who all hate
hate is just part of your life every
every second the the first thing you
lose is like empathy for people yeah I
didn't feel anything for for human
beings anymore
so it was very easy for me like to be
violent at them because I didn't see
them as human beings